it was a bad case she was framed my dad
did a lot of rough things in his life so
did I I went to jail for a crime that I
was guilty of that particular crime that
he did 38 years in prison for he was
innocent off and I'll take that to my
grave real awe percent I investigated
that case spoke to every witness they
recanted that testimony
we gave him a lie detector test prove
they lied at the trial the FBI was
complicit and turning them against my
dad it was a bad case she was framed
thousand percent people say well you
know he got away with so much that's not
how our system supposed to work they
have enough tools and weapons the
government to get people the right way
they're not supposed to do that no
matter what or who you are because if
they do it against the bad guys one day
they can do it against the good guys if
it suits them so why we say tell people
look you wouldn't want my dad's life